bonjour raphaël chez les bergers merci
de répondre à nos questions en direct ce
matin sur rtl france zéro voix pour 96
contre cette abstention c'est le vote
des députés et l'air hier soir vous avez
parlé je cite d'irresponsabilité de ce
gouvernement et damien abad le président
du groupe plr à l'assemblée a lui pointé
du doigt sur twitter la fracture au sein
du groupe lrm qu'est ce que vous
reprochez concrètement à l'exécutif
alors bon aujourd'hui de la prolongation
de l'état d'urgence a été a été actée
d'ailleurs on a fini par la route et
après après accord avec le sénat mais
sur le texte initial le gouvernement a
voulu organiser son irresponsabilité en
quelque sorte pour nous c'était
particulièrement inacceptable le
gouvernement aussi le créer un fichier
de traçage des des français atteint ou
non par le coronavirus et ce fichier à
une telle ampleur est initialement
n'avait investi peu de garanties que
c'est une sixième opposé vous êtes
député de la 4e circonscription du
haut-rhin l'un de vos collègues
alsaciens jean-luc ryder avait été le
premier parlementaire officiellement
touchés par le commis de 19 c'était en
mars dernier est ce que vous craignez le
retour à la vie parlementaire j'ai envie
de dire normale ou presque avec avec cd
confinement écoutez moi je suis bien
plus d'agacer par l'empêchement du
fonctionnement du parlement pendant
cette période de crise parce que on se
rend compte que pendant presque deux
mois le parlement n'a pas siégé il n'y a
pas eu d'expression politique n'y a pas
eu d'expression démocratique
moi je suis bien plus embêté par cela
que par le fait que nous parlementaires
devions quand on retourne à l'assemblée
à partir de lundi très progressivement
comme tous les français respecter un
certain nombre de mesures dans les
salles du mur réunion dans les couloirs
pour pour éviter que l'assemblée
nationale devienne un lieu de diffusion
du virus
on va faire comme tous les français moi
ce qui m'embête c'est pas de crainte de
ressent de retourner à l'assemblée
nationale mais c'est bien que pendant
deux mois on a bâillonné là
ambler nationale sous prétexte d' état
d'urgence sanitaire comme ça n'était
jamais arrivé
vous dites on a on a bâillonné
l'assemblée nationale justement votre
parti a fait savoir un durant ces
cinquante cinq jours de déconfinement
qu'il voulait une commission d' enquête
parlementaire pour je cite tirer les
leçons de l'épidémie
qu'est ce que vous attendez réellement
aujourd'hui il faut il faut faire la
lumière sur un certain nombre de choses
en art cette semaine un article dans le
journal le monde qui nous indique que
des centaines de millions de masques ont
été détruits par ce gouvernement
mais déjà même même encore en ce début
d'année alors même que la crise du
coronavirus avaient déjà éclaté le
gouvernement continuer à détruire des
masques du stock stratégique
il ya eu 13 ans premier ministre a en
partie démenties cette semaine en disant
qu'ils avaient 80 millions de masques
ont été récupérés un oui mais il n'a pas
il n'a pas démenti le fait que depuis le
début du quinquennat des centaines de
millions de masques ont été détruits et
qu' il n'y a eu aucune stratégie de
remplacement qui a été mise en place moi
je veux bien entendre que le stock était
peut-être périmés mais si le stock est
périmée on met en place une stratégie de
remplacement ont ré équipe on redoute la
france de ses équipements stratégiques
et on n'attend pas que la crise éclate
pour se rendre compte qu'il n'a pas
assez le fait que
élus locaux je pense par exemple à
christian estrosi du côté de nice arrive
à faire venir des masques en provenance
de chine et l'état traîne un petit peu
ça ça vous agace
moi je ça m'agace quand je constate
l'inefficacité de l'état et c'est
l'apprentissage de ces crises on a
multiplié les administrations les ars
rendez vous compte qu'on dépense la même
somme aujourd'hui de notre produit
intérieur brut pour la santé que les
allemands seulement les allemands
l'argent va directement dans les
hôpitaux sert à équiper les hôpitaux il
sert à payer les personnels alors qu'en
france on paye attaque structures
intermédiaires d'administration
intermédiaires qui au moment où elles
sont censées être efficaces pour gérer
la crise sont aux abonnés absents à
votre party les républicains ont plutôt
l'ump a déjà été au pouvoir
dernièrement vous êtes dans l'opposition
vous jouez votre rôle stanislas guérini
dès lors on m a déploré je cite que
l'opposition des confine ses vieux
réflexes politiciens mais si vous aviez
était au pouvoir aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que vous auriez fait sûrement la
majorité critique et a posteriori c'est
trop facile
qu'est ce que vous répondez mais écoutez
c'est vous savez stanislas guérini qui
s'offusquent communes comme voilà qui
fait le naïf pour s'offusquer que
certains dans la politique font un peu
de politique alors qu'il est le maître
en la matière c'est quand même c'est
quand même assez surprenant
qu'est ce qu'on aurait fait déjà on
aurait anticipé cote un stock de masques
stratégique arrivent à péremption ça ça
ça peut arriver mais bien plutôt que de
détruire de façon brute on commande on
remplace voilà un certain nombre de
choses à faire
ensuite on agit non pas dans la
précipitation avec sang froid
ce qu'on constate aussi aujourd'hui
c'est que le virus dans la moitié du
pays ne circule pas il n'a jamais appelé
on a enfermé la moitié des français dans
un territoire tant mieux ça les a
protégés où le virus ne circulait pas
parce qu'on a été incapable d'anticiper
suffisamment tôt alors que les signes d'
alerte a été lancée
on apprend dans le canard enchaîné cette
semaine que l'elysée était
vraisemblablement au courant dès la fin
de l'année dernière voilà autant
d'éléments qui par excès de confiance de
ce gouvernement par part par excès tout
simplement au l'ont empêché de d'avoir
un peu peur de craindre quand on
gouverne il faut il faut douter quand on
gouverne il faut douter et sans ce doute
on n'est pas à même de prendre de bonnes
décisions justement quelles décisions à
ce qu'il faut prendre par rapport aux 2
nouveau cluster en dordogne et dans la
vienne
est-ce que ça ça vous inquiète mais là
elle écoute et on a aujourd'hui donné
avec la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
au gouvernement tous les moyens d'agir
là aussi chacun ses responsabilités en
tant que parlementaire nous avons
créer l'état d'urgence sanitaire en
créant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
nous avons donné au gouvernement les
moyens les plus larges et moyens les
plus larges d'agir et d'intervenir
charge à lui aujourd'hui d'user de ses
moyens les moyens ils en disposent
on les lui a donné maintenant il est
responsable de son action et c'est ce
qui est un peu embêtant dans cette crise
c'est qu'il ya une tentative de
construction d'un discours politique de
la part d' en marche de dire voyez les
oppositions conte de la politique
oui mais sauf que quand on doit être au
rendez-vous quand on doit prendre des
décisions on les prend et ensuite eu
n'agissent pas et continue d'ajouter
d'agiter lé chiffon rouge du débat qui
est pourtant nécessaire
on est dans une démocratie on doit être
fier de pouvoir dire qu'on débat même en
temps de crise ces mots de la fin merci
à raphaël chez les bergers d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes débuté les républicains de la
4e circonscription du haut rhin